language listen is supported by patreon
patrons recently got an extra episode
kind of as a bonus plus they get
episodes early unedited if there are any
edits and the huge win of knowing that
they're helping this weird show exist so
if you want to support player watch
listen click the link in the description
or go to patreon.com
should we just should we just
um record this entire thing without ever
addressing the lack of Mike or Troy the
presence of Liam you're just 100 play it
straight what do you mean that's not
Troy yeah right I've been here the whole
time I directed the whole of stray Gods
you know it was it was a really
difficult project he pulled out the
accent and everything I think that was
really good
I can also do the American accent very
easily get them to do an Australian it's
a disaster
um you do the we grow up with it yeah
it's true you do the um
the like my news broadcaster that's my
favorite one
um that can also do Valley Girl
the valley girl one comes awfully
naturally to you but I think the um the
kind of AI
I've done robots in four games actually
and an animated series what does that
say about it makes sense that I could do
a great robot voice yeah but I think you
should really kind of search inward
about the subtext of your emotional I
can tell you the subtext Austin I know
what it is
that's uh that's a neurodivergence is
what that is
um yeah exactly I think you're I've been
diagnosed it's fine uh you've been
diagnosed and then flipped it into
professional opportunity yeah and then
exploited it it's great uh welcome to
play watch listen we're entering at the
start of the show because the setup's a
little different today uh obviously
that's Austin wintry he is a video game
music boy and podcast host and this is
Liam um who's our first ever guest on
this show did you know that Liam did I
tell you you're our first ever guest
technically Craig Miller was on for 10
seconds
um
Mike is not feeling well
and I spoke to Tori last weekend
obviously we got a lot of comments about
Troy not doing the Show recently it
seems like Troy will not be able to do
the show for the foreseeable future uh
but we'll have him back that we can yeah
like we had him on I think he was only
maybe on two episodes this year anyway
uh was the last of this episode so I
think probably like the next time Troy
has something big coming out we'll uh
haven't come back but today we have Liam
Liam who are you why are you here
uh my name is lame as previously
mentioned I am the managing director of
uh summerfall Studios I almost forgot
the name of the company that I
co-founded because I'm currently I'm
currently in Stockholm in Sweden
extremely chat like so I I apologize
um but yeah I uh run some local Studios
with David Gator and Ellie young and we
had the great pleasure of working with
Mr assemitory here and Troy Baker on
stray God's the role-playing musical
comes out this week guys this week sorry
be out by the time this uh yeah by the
time you will see this yeah I'm
streaming it I think on Thursday uh I'm
very excited to know about that yeah I
was going to ask you if you wanted to
join but we can figure that out later so
I'm not just putting you on the spot
um and before we discuss stray Gods uh
if you will indulge me I just wanted to
talk to you about something else
entirely
um I saw Taylor Swift Last Night
ah yeah I saw your was it okay little
glimpses it's the most insane thing I
have ever experienced and I now look at
the world differently for contact I'm
not being hyperbolic no I mean look it's
it's already made all this uh all this
uh headlines as the most financially
successful tour in music history I
underst I feel differently about Mankind
guys uh so I'm not a Swifty which which
Swifty is the word they use for like
people who are like hardcore Taylor
Swift fans okay so like the only songs I
knew are the really popular ones I'm not
like
I don't pay attention to it that she I
guess she does like coded stuff and
people get really into deciphering
everything I'm not that kind of Swift
person but I don't know about those
songs but your life is all changed
um yeah so I I went because let's phrase
it this way you weren't a Swifty going
in I still don't think I am I don't want
those people to uh ruin my life for
saying this but they're a little bit
much
love a live performance and uh I love
experiences so I'll pay a lot of money
for a crazy experience and that is
absolutely what I had I
have never
heard anything so loud so consistently
three hours straight of people screaming
at the top of their lungs it didn't
relent once I had to put headphones in
um which I guess you should do for a lot
of live music anyway but I don't go
anywhere I yeah we've been to a lot of
like we went and saw Muse we're gonna go
to like a metal festival soon
is that the one with like Iron Maiden
we're thinking about going to that you
should it's it's where they do Coachella
uh near Palm Springs right I might go um
yeah I mean I'm not surprised that you
especially as a musician won't always
know to do that I never had before and
for reference majority of the music
shows that I've been to are metal like I
was going to it was called sound wave in
Australia if you remember Liam
um yeah good times uh and it's almost
all of them this is like maybe the only
actual pop concert I've ever been to and
the fact that the swifties goes so much
harder than all of them
by so much like I went in and and I
think that so far I went extended for
larger shows can fit a hundred thousand
people
I understand what a pop star is now like
it it's just
like sure Taylor Swift was there and
she's great but it was more the crowd
and that amount of people just all at
the same time losing their [__] minds
over one human and just like I kept
being like how must she feel
like to happen yeah that would be that
famous
I was just talking about this with
Angela uh uh a week or two ago where
it was like I was like the number of
followers that someone in her position
has across different social media
platforms is literally
like
continents of people well not even like
Costa Rica for example is like six
million people or five million people or
something like that and I was like she
could lose 5 million followers and it
would look like a rounding error it
wouldn't even notice like you're talking
about hundreds of millions yeah and I
was like at that point I wonder if
people feel real to you like I don't
even know what
I just my brain can't
fathom it and I can't it also doesn't
seem like
it doesn't really seem
fun no not at all I mean celebrity seems
awful generally imagine that at like an
extreme insane level where literally you
know a sixth of the world follows you
yeah it's crazy I previously felt like
I had a theory that I might have even
said this on the show Michael Jackson is
the most famous person ever and I don't
know if we are able to beat that again
because now everyone has like micro
followings but last night I was like oh
maybe Taylor Swift is up there with
Michael Jackson and that like I think it
would be horrific
um but yeah like how do you go anywhere
or do anything you can't leave your own
house you can't live a life no because
you belong to everybody like you can't
go to the beach people are allowed to
harass you effectively because you're a
celebrity like what do you you can't do
anything it sounds awful but I used to
have an entirely constructed world it's
or just a nice house
yeah and it's it watching her you know
play piano whatever she was doing she
had a couple of acoustic sets which was
cool and just like if she smiles people
scream like I just and I can't even
imagine what it would be like from my
perspective looking at that many
people and just like at what point is
she not human like it's not a human
experience it's literally homelander uh
yeah from the boys where she could just
point at someone in the crowd and go
kill them and someone could probably do
it they would just ravenously consume
them like zombies nuts that's that's
what I mean about like my impression of
mankind is slightly different now I like
I had I had a version of Taylor Swift
that existed in my head
that I think is like a brand that's been
curated which is like I saw her as a
sort of wholesome homely cat mother like
that's kind of what was in my head and
now
oh sorry no it means a different thing
in America I always forget I get chewed
up on that at SMS yeah normally in
Australia means like cozy off the home
it's [__] up actually that for you
guys it's ugly woman
yeah you're all wrong it's homeless is
homely gendered I didn't think I thought
that I thought
American it traditionally means ugly
woman
no
it's such a weird one but but tell me
um but now after seeing it before I was
like no no you are just like a
full-blown Mega Corporation of a human
pop star she's you know the um very good
very confident
um very sexy in a way that I didn't
expect her to be performance wise like
beautiful costuming I was like this is
yeah like this is and at what point do
you stop
like
like at a certain when you just have
that much money don't you go
I'm gonna I'm bowing out I'm gonna go
chill in a castle on an island somewhere
right I think yeah but by reputation
I've I've uh I've never met her but I've
I've talked with folks that have worked
with her in various capacities and by
all reputation behind closed doors and
in more isolated professional settings
she actually really does care about the
music and care about her work and care
about making music yeah like I think
that no I think she would be doing it if
she was making far less than she is the
fact that she is so successful is just
validation that she's doing something
that people are responding to True
obviously but um it's not the money
isn't the means to some end it's the
other way around uh as far as as far as
like and that's the ideal like when I
look at it and you know yeah of course
there's like all the you know there's
merchandising and there's all the
various ways that like it gets um uh uh
sort of the profit is sort of uh
maximized but
um of of of all the people that you
could look at who are in that sort of
demographic of level of success like big
movie stars big pop stars
um
she's one of the most beloved for for at
least very effectively projecting that
she cares about her fans I mean like all
the taking to uh Ticketmaster to task
um for example and and being like I
don't want there to be Pat like
gatekeeping to people to come to my
shows and so I'm like hey if she's
talking give I think every part of her
crew a million dollar bonus this week
um so I guess it's that I'm coming from
a very self-centered perspective which
is like if I were that famous I would
want to stop as soon as possible but
maybe it's like something she's so used
to
that's even true about you though
because you like you make stuff yeah but
that you don't have to make
like I'm making it because it's fun and
it's small
okay it's a fair difference way too big
I have some friends who are like you
know the most successful YouTubers on
the planet like
the most like very well known and I had
a conversation with one of them recently
where they were like yeah I'm just like
waiting until I have enough money that I
can disappear from the internet and I
was like how do you not already have it
there's no hub for any of us if you
don't have enough money already
so that's what I'm thinking is once you
get once you become rich you just keep
wanting more rich and then you don't
know what standards of living changes
right to a bunch of celebrities about
this and it's like just your the the
rectangle of your life shifts like and
it continually changes and you don't
notice it happening until one day you
look back and you're like oh my God uh
and it's kind of too late to go back and
your perception of everything is so
warped and and like these are lovely
sweet people who mean incredibly well
and who are very articulate and smart
but you know just the experience of
having that much because it's different
now money it's just it's yeah it's just
different now you're you are describing
and way the you know the Shea Stadium
story of you know the Beatles The
Beatles like the Apex of beetles Mania
where they they played a show where the
audience was so loud they couldn't hear
their own instruments and they quit
touring after that they basically they
basically became a band that does Studio
albums you know that was the mission
after Shea Stadium of like well live
gigs are just they suck now
um like yeah even though even though
it's a good thing people are so
ravenously in love with you
that they they just don't know how to
contain themselves yeah the Beatles we
didn't need like one of them got in a
lot of trouble for saying the Beatles
are bigger than Jesus but it's like well
it kind of had a point
like Taylor Swift up there with bigger
than Jesus to be honest yeah it was it
was just oh yeah I mean just absolutely
unfathomable the amount of of people and
I'm also very used to going to uh
concerts that mostly have men uh in the
crowd because I'm going to see like
System of a Down yeah that's the last
one um I mean Blink 182 is still mostly
men and I think mostly women is like a
lot
more screaming like I don't know if
that's just because it was Taylor Swift
but it was almost entirely women which
was actually like a really nice Vibe
people were handing out these friendship
bracelets
um it was very cute yeah and I've never
seen more pink in a stadium in my life
she was like like oh look at another
pick it was actually like very nice uh
and you went and saw the Barbie movie so
I did nowhere near as much Pink as Sofi
Stadium last night it was just um that
place is gigantic though I mean that
place has like
pushing close to a hundred thousand
capacity yeah
75 normally and then they said for
bigger shows it can be expanded to just
over a hundred thousand so the last time
I was there was for the Super Bowl and
this was bigger than the Super Bowl like
it legitimately like was more sold out
than Super Bowl so I think I think the
capacity was probably a hundred thousand
which is just
yeah insane just a wild unfathomable
experience where I couldn't stop
thinking about what it must be like to
be Taylor Swift in that moment like just
broke my brain
looking at this volume of people because
they gave us those like light up
wristbands that flash and type of music
so you could just see everyone all the
time and it's just
unfathomable what humans can like get to
be like change something
because like normally in a show like
when you're on stage you actually can't
see the audience and so those wristbands
make it so that she sees every that's
why individual person yeah
yeah crazy and I know that that's part
of the point right as I recall like she
wants to be able to see and connect with
everyone in the audience I think that
was the part of the narrative around it
Rosie's easy like quarter mile away from
me
[Laughter]
she wanted to run for president I think
she'd succeed it's just yeah just just
weird how considering our prior
president's biggest claim to fame was
being a reality TV star I think that
Americans like it as as much uh as much
uh of a sort of claim if not a
marginally better fight
yeah it's just just unfathomable the way
we like we just pick someone you know
like she's still just a regular person
really but we just like someone just
sort of gets selected and then just
same Planet as everybody else but just
become that and that like no matter what
now I guess with her she can't really
retire because she will always people
will always know what she looks like and
who she is she's always going to be
Taylor Swift yeah and you just can't
see what life is like without it I don't
know so everything Fades I mean look at
look at um
look at uh someone like Dave Chappelle
who he disappeared from public life for
a long time and moved to like rural
where like where where I can't even like
Ohio or so and like this he was one of
the most famous comedians on the planet
for year after year
do wolves even the height of his Fame no
no question I for sure like yeah it's
it's magnitudes beyond but I feel like
all things eventually
like public attention can be quite short
and she's managed to do something
amazing to yeah like she's sustained a
level of popularity already even that's
pretty impressive and I don't see any
reason why she seemingly couldn't keep
that going for a while but if she just
put a hard stop
really Jesus yeah she's like sustained
it for a very [__] long time yeah
well Chappelle Madonna right
good point she's very famous
like and still very famous even though
she's kind of stopped making people know
her on Tick Tock now I think because she
posted that horrific that's bathtub
thing
um but Chappelle still sells out
stadiums well he's he's he's obviously
had a Resurgence and and
controversy certainly yeah helps yeah
but he chose yeah he leaned back in
that's the point um but the the but but
just like independent of that there was
there was a time where
he had been out of the public
Consciousness for years and I'm sure he
was able to live some semblance of a
normal life because like I bet the
people in his small town were like oh
yeah that's Dave like you you get yeah
pretty famous but that's also like now
he's Dave to us or whatever and he
probably chose a super isolated
community in part for that reason
um I would guess you know yeah true I
don't know obviously these are things I
I it even the small scale like when I've
had folks over here to the studio before
who were
recognizable by folks on the street it's
always fascinating where we're hanging
they're relaxed it's obviously a you
know it's chill where it's usually
pretty much every case it's because
we're we have some professional reason
to be in the room together and then I
feel them
as they're leaving they're putting on
the sunglasses and they're doing the the
thing in order to get to their car
um just to not be stopped basically and
it's like
yeah I was
this is what I always thought was so
cool about being composers you can work
on a stuff that's potentially heard and
appreciated or enjoyed or whatever by
millions of people but you
effectively never get bothered because
people don't know what John Williams
looks like yeah
John Williams Hans Zimmer Danny Elfman
look at the most well-known composers
maybe Danny Elfman he gets recognized
he's a little iconic only recently
because he's been performing live in the
last couple years and like leaning into
this kind of like I'm a 70 year old guy
covered in tattoos who's astonishingly
ripped for a literal 70 year old
and yeah like so he's kind of
carved out a slightly unique I guess
he's a performer now as well because I
know he's yeah composing his personality
now like yeah
you know because he was he was the front
man of Oingo Boingo in the 80s before he
that's right
holy [__] I forgot that yeah oh yeah it
was on screen he was on screen singing
Dead Man's Party in uh in um oh [__]
it's embarrassing that I'm blanking on
the moon wow Austin I can't believe you
would forget a uh a movie in which a
musical Thing Happened I understand if
you want to leave it's fine no actually
I should be the one to leave I I don't
deserve uh this spot amongst your
company uh well look I know that
obviously we have Liam here and it would
be yes uh it would be remiss to not uh
pick his brain about stray Gods but do
you mind if I if I briefly also talk
about uh in in the vein of like shocking
levels of success uh a lot Taylor Swift
just a brief moment about Baldur's Gate
because I was just gonna say beautiful
Segway yeah
Taylor yeah the swifties of d d uh who
are appreciating Larry in this week yeah
I I just want to say I found
this weird
like thread that kind of went a little
bit viral of effectively developers
being like this is [__] don't don't
pay too much attention to the like you
saw this article that I'm sure made the
rounds of of of basically saying this is
Rockstar the quote was this is Rockstar
level scope nonsense and like fans
should not treat this as a new Benchmark
it's it's too far outside the data set
and it felt like Romney tweet about it I
did not see what you're referring to
because I I don't think I spent enough
time on Twitter anymore but I did see a
tweet from Rami that was about Baldur's
Gate 3 that was something about like in
response to that in response to this
conversation uh my biggest take is I
think he said something along the lines
of I wish that Publishers would um take
more risks on games like this that's the
part of it that's really unrealistic
yeah but I didn't see the source that
caused that controversy which is
ultimately basically people being like
this game's unrealistically good
it felt like it felt like the the most
cynical take was it felt like fellow
Developers
feeling like holy [__] this is so
beloved I I'm being so threatened by it
and being here like jealous wow yeah
before that's a real shame
it it is very good like but I mean I
love wearing I genuinely cannot wait to
play it wait to play it but because like
our game's coming out in just a few days
and I've been traveling I haven't had a
chance to even sit down I asked you on
this podcast to promote a different game
even though he also comes out this week
sorry game let's talk about photos
oh it's genuinely such an impressive
achievement yeah and I think I think
people forget that larion is like
totally independent it's owned by Sven
and his wife and like they have had a
team of 400 people working on this game
for over six years it is I played it
four years ago at a previous achievement
yeah holy crap which is crazy
Dangerfield it was the 1986 Rodney
Dangerfield movie back to school thank
you
thank you in the eyes of play what's
listen you're allowed to stay
um I I was 400 people football was gate
three but I imagine not four that's so
big foreign
development but like I'm sure that for
at its peak and that would have just
been the people internally too like
normally when we give these numbers
where we're cutting out Outsourcing
Studios which also do a huge amount of
work particularly around like
environment art yeah assets Etc serious
what that breakdown is for them like
what's the difference for intern because
like for example I know their composer
is an internal he's staff yes and that's
not normal yeah that's internal huh
like obsidian had an internal composer
for the longest time and he composed all
of the games yeah he uh he is incredible
um yeah
Mr Bell is I mean he doesn't work better
anymore but you know he did something's
most famous yeah but Sony it's so good I
didn't know that role existed I never
heard of it being internal before it's
rare it's not common but like Darren is
uh internal with supergiant as well he's
a staff yeah that one makes sense so but
does that mean that most composers are
also audio directors or are they just
like no no vast majority are not wow
most games that audio directors among
other things tasked with hiring the
composer and being there
yeah so if you're just a composer
you're worthless yeah but my head is
like how is that work for you all the
time
I mean they often is very very lucky
yeah if you're very very good but the
other thing is like from a studio
perspective it's way cheaper if you just
have to pay someone's salary then if you
have to you know pay them properly for
the rights to what they're creating
that's interesting it's probably a very
controversial take
is one of one of the pro Liam is
definitely one of the most um
like Pro Corporation
replacing Mike if anything it's the
opposite it's it's Liam is one of the
most um supportive of the considerations
of outsourcers I would are to put it as
broadly as possible
um uh like typically we are we are
comparatively quite low on the food
chain
um but also I don't think that's an
unfair trade we get a lot of we get a
lot of sovereignty in exchange for that
um and that that's actually worth at
least in my case I feel that's that's
quite valuable
um you know you're not you're not bound
to the fate of one project or one Studio
the way everybody else is and that's
that's one of those reasons why you know
internal uh profit sharing for example
amongst the core Dev team that is not
extended to outsourcers as a default way
of being I don't think is particularly
unfair because if that thing tanks
they're out of a job I'm not I can go
look for another job I can also land
another job before I even finish this
job yeah and so like our risk assessment
is totally different yeah and I think
it's I think it's perfectly Fair
um but all that said Liam is a very very
gracious in his treatment
um uh regardless uh in a way that is is
atypical uh and um I've known than I've
known you Austin
it's been a long time
since I was a teenager Liam I think I
met you when I was 19. well In fairness
that was six six months ago but
um
uh
[Laughter]
Liam I refer to as the uh when we first
met and I was getting his you know like
story of what do you do who are you I
quickly came to the conclusion Liam is
Australian Megan scavio uh that's not
bad
you see that
at least in those days that was that was
the role you were pivoting out of uh
when we met basically and that's really
interesting Megan scavia for anyone who
doesn't know uh runs dice
um but is also I don't know if this is
how you meant it Austin but a very like
warm smiley
very kind I'm always very happy to see
Megan and I would say I would feel the
same about you Liam well and also that's
what I like and she also ran GDC before
Dice and she was like she was like the
professional make sure everybody knows
each other person like I met so many
people through her over the years
because she just was this magnet to like
you just if you were where she was other
people who were noteworthy it would be
nearby but invariably and it seems like
Liam has you know the was the Australian
ecosystem version of that I think
everyone I've ever met it's like I know
Liam yeah there's something about
running events so like I used to work um
uh with the game developers Association
of Australia and and ran a game connect
to Asia Pacific Australia's game
development conference for several years
and uh I think that that
kind of cement you as a central figure
whether you want to be or not uh because
the people of the Keynotes you have to
coordinate people like you go overseas
you represent the country you know for
for a very brief period I was probably
the person that people thought about
when they thought about game development
in Australia
um and uh it was yeah it was a weird
time you were talking about tolerable
types of Fame it's just a couple of
games
that I've I think when I was when I was
much younger like I I studied to be an
actor before I got into games
um and I used to think I wanted to be
famous and now that I actually know
famous people I'm like no please please
no please just like let me be well known
within the sphere of people who
appreciate what I do I'd like to be
respected by my peers yeah that's it
it's fine uh well you're doing a great
job Liam and thank you for joining us uh
to talk about
this has been a crash course on the
normal goings-on yeah I liked it oh yeah
we were always worried that if we had a
guest it would [__] up the show but I'm
glad to do wow ow uh absolutely not I'll
drive to stay off topic is is well with
with Liam here as well um so we've heard
from Austin about this game for about
three gods for quite some time I think
we probably had like three episodes that
have almost entirely been about stray
Gods yeah I've been hearing about it for
what feels like years I'm so sorry no no
I'm so sorry it'll be you too to be fair
um how are you feeling this week about
it finally coming out
it's weird because I like originally
obviously we were coming out on the
third and then Baldur's Gate moved to
the third we were like we don't want to
be on the same baseball as a gate and
we've still got some issues with
consoles so like let's move out a little
bit so we move to the 10th but
unfortunately that meant that the game
is gonna [__] while I'm on holiday on
the other side of the world without a
laptop so it's just like really weird
feeling are you talking to us now
potato
excellent that's how we want our
potatoes honestly like beautifully in
Focus I don't want it
so are you gonna try and let yourself
have the holiday Americans call that
vacation by the way if you call it
holiday they get confused
um are you gonna try and just have your
holiday or do you think you'll pay
attention to the reception I'm over here
for like a month basically oh wow so
um yeah that's awesome because uh well
this is like I haven't really had a
proper holiday since we started so I
think I had I had a two-week break in
like a proper break in the last like
five years
um and so uh the amount of fires this
guy was putting out on a daily basis
just to because it's just normal Game
Dev right like it's not even it's not
even that it was like some troubled
production our the team was lovely there
was no big like blowout drama that kind
of stuff like hard but yeah and and if
even just the calendar of like a cast of
this size and and like complexity of
schedules oh my God trying to coordinate
the voice actors
that took years of my life
uh yeah I can't even imagine all of
those people's schedules
well and bearing in mind also with Troy
as our director we had to find the
intersection of Troy's availability and
each of them and then a studio available
like it's wild we I think we ended up
working with like seven or eight
different Studios just to make sure that
we could yeah yeah it was it was wild
um but like our primary partner studio
um out loud audio who were like
brilliant they're based in Burbank they
did the vast majority of sessions
um yeah like it feels it's it's super
weird coming up to release it's been
five years of my life
um and that's very hard to comprehend
and also like it's been probably what
like four years of us working together
Austin then I guess
in terms of like I mean we met five
years ago uh and then and then uh and
then you know things kind of
ramped up yeah you know it was like a
sort of slow and steady burn for the
first probably year and a half and then
but I always think uh Ellie Ellie was
commenting on Instagram earlier today
and made me remember that
you know you all were here you and David
and Ellie and Laura
and yeah we were we we christened the
pandemic because you all yeah you all
had to change your flight because you
thought we're going to be we won't be
able to get back in the country uh like
that stuck or thought in L.A very close
because we were we were over for the
game developers conference and so we
were like okay let's spend like two
weeks with Austin starting to work on
all of the songs like very very early
conceptual like let's go through things
let's get all on the same page and thank
[__] Godly did because then like you
know the pandemic I didn't see you again
the entirety of songwriting yeah
um and if I think if I I I can't even
the idea of having not done that if we
had skipped to that
yeah but you got a little bit before
that
like um
five and six hour meetings where we we
talked through a scene we you know I
[__] around on the piano and say like
well I can kind of imagine it moving
like this and having this kind of vibe
and and we were able to like the first
handful of scenes really kind of
step through them in a way yeah and also
with Laura coming over and being able to
kind of like get those first little
taste tests that one's really cool her
voice feels with certain registers and
all that sort of stuff
um yeah we were kind of picturing doing
that you know the whole time like a lot
of yeah you know like recurring and and
spending a lot of time in the studio and
having multiple actors in the studio at
the same time was also something Troy
was very felt strongly about because we
really wanted to do that and then it was
fully fully forbade it oh of course
even though out loud is quite literally
down the block from me not even down the
street like I could hit them with a rock
um uh we weren't allowed in the booth
because uh the sad rules were basically
like yeah the covet so even though it's
that you had to do it all by Zoom yeah
damn because the only the only way we
could put people in the booth together
was if they uh had both had PCR tests
um like that day
and so uh like the the idea of trying to
do that for everyone was insane because
those costs like those were a few
hundred bucks and they were like hard to
find at the time yeah I was when I was
going into I was still doing stuff with
Rooster Teeth occasionally and I'd have
to get a PCR test for it which I always
was like sick free PCR test they're like
150 or something at the time yeah it was
a driving through and yeah I had to do
it every time that's so nuts obviously a
lot of Ragnarok would have also been
developed through covert but they had
figured that all out before I got that
because I started in November of that
year so it was like they had figured out
whatever the workflow looked like for
remote work
you had to figure it out like right at
the start it was wild and like figure it
out while working on something that
nobody had ever done before yeah and so
like there were no established pipelines
because we were really making them up
ourselves yeah you didn't even have a
pipeline for the game let alone for
doing it remotely that's nuts I would
argue and I would say tell me if you
agree with this Liam because I would
actually say that of all the times
within our production for kova to have
started that was probably the best
because it's not like we were halfway
through recording our cast one way and
then had to shift to recording them
another way we hadn't really even begun
the cast recordings that feels like that
would have been way worse
I think shifting gears would have been
much much harder yeah
um but it was it was a a wild experience
yeah like I often think like I don't
think I'm ever going to work on a
project like that ever again
absolutely it just just like working on
something that's so different and
interesting so unique and intricate
exactly and where everyone was so keen
and on board like I really hope we can
replicate that but like straight Gods
really was like and continues to be
incredibly special as a project
what do you I've asked Austin this I
think I asked him last episode what do
you hope people take away from it more
than anything else like what do you want
players to
think
or take
I just wanted to have a good time
ultimately like I just like we make
games because we
uh have a a morbid vaccination with
um you know making ourselves like work
hard and feel bad clearly but I think
also because we we want to connect with
other people and when I create
experiences that people enjoy and that
are meaningful to them and I think uh
really the thing I hope that people walk
away with is
connection with the characters that
we've created and this this space that
we created and
um Dave often talks about uh you know
songs as being a shortcut to the heart
and that's how we kind of tried to use
the songs in straight Gods was like we
had this fantastic you know Dave's
superpowers characters like everyone
knows like he creates these incredible
casts of characters and so he really
leaned into that and I really hope that
people will just walk away having fallen
in love with these characters that have
been brought to life so incredibly by
this
insane cast of performers with music by
some of the world's best you know like
that's pretty in love with that Minotaur
look
he is like everyone's favorite to talk
about him
yeah that's it's not near the start of
the game right because like I said I'm
streaming it's like in the middle okay I
might be able to
how fast you play if I don't understand
this because for me I'm like it's pretty
set length because I play a very certain
way but the reports that people come in
like some people can finish the game in
like four and a half hours and some
people finish the game in like 12 hours
and I do not understand how that
variation is possible but like your
average playthrough is probably like
like six
10 six to eight somewhere in there so I
reckon I reckon the Minotaur section is
probably a smack bang in the middle
there we'll see if I can get that maybe
not but one one big downside here is
because of the strikes like I'm
obviously gonna play the game and I'm
very excited about it and I was like
well you should join me but we don't
know if he can
so he can because uh so video games are
not affected right worried about how if
it's seen as promotion if that would be
seen as scabbing anyway
so there's two things here one of them
is public perception
the other one is Sag the actual rules uh
like the actual rules the actual rules
around video games like I'm promoting
video games that's totally fine we're
still working is it all still allowed to
talk about yeah because obviously the
actors are absolutely a much bigger part
of this and they feel like they are of
even most games
sorry
it's super important and like so uh the
interactive contract is not struck so uh
video game performers can still talk
about the projects they're in they can
still record they can still do all that
kind of stuff and for the record Troy
very specific ones
yeah same thing television animation is
also not struck but feature animation is
and yes and like live action everything
I think but but um but uh for the record
you know Anjali Troy Laura
um have all within the last
24 hours yeah share shared stuff you
know like so I don't there there and all
of them obviously
yeah like because we we would never have
asked people to like promote or even
given the materials destroy your
reputation for that we would have we
would have been like hey
um you know please like abide by the
strike like yeah I'm your friends just
do it do it on the DL yeah even when we
went to the the Oppenheimer screening uh
Jeff Keeley put together an opera
oppenheimer's screening with universal
and um we were like can we go to this
because is that not Universal but it was
not promotional in that they were not
allowing photos
yeah so a bunch of actors were there but
you like they weren't taking photos of
us they weren't advertising it none of
that so it was deemed to be okay you're
still allowed to go see a movie you just
can't promote a movie it's a lot
it's it's a really fascinating time like
because we we were really worried about
this strike and like because we we don't
want to do anything that hurts people's
livelihoods we don't want to recommend
things but
um I've counted to you know things that
are good for them
um so yeah we wanted to make sure that
was we were all in the clear glad
everybody then I might try and recruit
more of those people for streams because
like I'd love to have Erica uh such a
fan yeah video games and animation
A-Okay it's just like feature stuff TV
Etc that's struck
um stag stag has posted stuff about this
before you can go digging for it but it
is super interesting like it's it's a
I mean it's it's a weird time we had
time to live in L.A
like I've been to like parties and stuff
recently where people are just like yeah
the strikes because like one of my
friends is a writer's assistant
um and she just got fired because she
can't work anymore and like they told
her we'll hire you back as soon as the
strike's done but we can't keep giving
you discount are you because you can't
work yeah so she has to I guess the
mandated she goes to the strikes twice a
week
um but it's just zero income while this
is all happening um it's it's yeah it's
such a fascinating uh game of chicken in
War of Attrition kind of situation
because obviously the headlines made the
rounds of some unnamed like Studio
Executives saying like you know we can
basically last longer well while they
starve but then I saw another headline
the other day that said Universal I
think it was Universal or Warner's like
War chess savings was dipping below 100
million dollars and it's like these
companies can't run on fumes yeah they
go shareholders they have to appease
like it's hot I think it's almost harder
for them than it is for most have said
who have second jobs anyway because they
have to like I don't know it's either
way it's a bloody it's like yeah
irrespective of kind of who wins the
who's harder for this Olympics it's it
is brutal on both and and it's in both
interests to resolve it because
basically both are just burning
cash and not bringing anything in like
every party involved is
is not in a good is not benefiting from
I wonder if there's a hit to the
California economy
I'm sure they would be well long time
I think so much of La is like Hollywood
funded yeah but if war was filmed here I
bet it would be an even bigger impact
because so much
it's yeah it's more straight it'd
probably be like places that film
regularly Vancouver
well there used to be a lot in Louisiana
and uh I don't know if they had huge tax
incentives that were making it like
almost like a little mini Hollywood
Outpost there but I don't know if that's
still going certainly was for a while
much like Atlanta you know like Tyler
Perry built a [__] unbelievable
state-of-the-art Mega complex out there
for shooting and just fully relocated
everything and makes tons of stuff in
Atlanta and I imagine like strikes are
hugely impactful on their local economy
because it's probably a pretty big part
of it at this point yeah well I'm glad
that you guys
um
you know the games industry is not
struck so you guys aren't affected
though at the same time it's not like I
want to say glad you're not affected
when it's like no 100 people need to
strike the abstract but glad that people
are still allowed to be excited about
the game
100 I mean I think the reality is like
the interactive contracts when it is
because the reason that things are
being struck on I don't know the correct
terminology but uh the reason a strike
is occurring is because those contracts
have run out and so it is the it is the
negotiation period whereas the
interactive con contract has like a
different period so when this contract
runs out it's very possible that
you know video game actors will also
choose to strike because of these right
because they're still sag obviously and
I know it's still sag production like
any other video game acting I've done
has still been sag
um
but the uh is there like a video game
subset that has to yeah and PTP yeah so
there's basically the way that sag works
for anyone because like I think this is
pretty mysterious to most people so yeah
I know more about WTO than I know about
100 and I well I think it's clearer to
be honest but sag has a series of
contracts for like each each medium has
a different contract
um so you have like television you have
feature films you have the interactive
contracts under which again sits you
have uh animation you have uh like audio
and sound recording you have like so
it's all of these different contracts
and they are full sag also includes
singers uh session singers are also part
of sag which is it's interesting track
so yeah it's it's all they're all like
separate and so I think that some of
them just happened to like be negotiated
at the same time and so when the
interactive one is up it'll be really
interesting to see what happens because
I think uh the last time that it was
negotiated there were a lot of things
that sag wanted that they didn't get
um so it is going to be it's gonna be
very interesting but there's also like
no
like the video game industry really
doesn't work the same way as Hollywood
does so there's no like a peak body to
negotiate with in quite the same way so
yeah that's really interesting that's my
understanding that there's not really an
equivalent to the AMT amp what is it am
T yeah the in games there isn't sort of
some entity on behalf of like and it
would be on behalf of who like the
Publishers Microsoft Sony
differently that like yeah I can't even
fathom like the closest thing we have to
even a board is the esa and that
wouldn't apply to workers
yeah like it's it's really interesting
so yeah I'm very curious to see well
does the esa really do anything other
than help Define the ratings that that
are sort of sort of I don't I mean and
and I guess E3 but I I don't I don't
know that they really do I think they
sometimes put out public statements
about things but like well yeah they
have this really they're the peak buddy
games in the US so like technically
speaking I think they they ask they
respond to uh different like PR crises
they help to they do research they do a
ton of different stuff
um and
I think you'll do less nowadays
definitely the closest we have to a
board but I don't think they'd be the
people you'd negotiate they would not be
the people to negotiate with because you
know there's no yeah it's it's very
power over it's not like it's not like
the essay governs how EA operates no no
one knows yeah
yeah it's a fascinating
um Andrew Wilson he's one of my favorite
Impressions to do games hi everybody
Andrew Wilson here
um also
um I feel like
to complicate things even further
self-distribution is a million times
more viable for games than for film
really so like which putting out
but yeah exactly because now you have 50
000 Indies like who is super giant
supposed to talk to uh if they're
supposed to be because they're like we
we chart our own course we do our own
thing you know like it's the same stupid
giant uh use no they don't work with the
Union like they do stuff outside of the
Union they have their own contracts that
they do
um and uh you know the thing that I find
really interesting is about
the fragmentation of this space is like
particularly around audio and audio
rights and uh technical reproduction
you're just saying that to Panda to
Austin
all right
um no but like mechanical
um royalties uh which are royalties that
like musicians get when something is
like played on the radio or
um like these are organized and paid
through specific uh bodies that video
games doesn't have
and steam won't pay this out so like
Boston doesn't get money like unless a
publisher gives it to him from Steam if
one of his soundtracks is sold through
Steam or if
um Steam
won't
if the soundtrack gets stalled through
Steam they don't pay they will composer
no they'll pay they'll pay like the
publisher negotiate it yeah exactly
and then you negotiate with your
publisher yeah it's just the default
assumption is most the vast majority of
games selling on Steam the publisher
will have full and total control of the
music as a subset so if they deem as a
as their own internal agreement with the
composer to share in anything that's on
them to decide and it's it's a wild west
of yes does that mean they would be
allowed to sell your score on Steam like
the soundtrack on Steam without asking
or would that have to be right they
would have to have the rights to do that
okay wow yeah which would have been that
would have been like
basically if if if if that were
happening it would have meant when we
were first negotiating I was like well
if you're willing to pay more up front
then sure like I've had that before I've
had projects where they said
can we cut you a check so that we never
have to keep track of royalties like are
you like what would be an amount that
would make you feel like much more
convenient
oh yeah well that was the thing like on
that particular the one I'm especially
thinking of I was like
I kind of did some napkin math and I was
like I'm pretty sure that the amount
they're offering is more than I would
ever make uh on royalties on this so
like sold okay have fun enjoy your album
uh and um but then there's other times
where you're like this one has potential
you know and and and
I will add an interesting
um wrinkle
um is
the the those organization those
societies that Liam was alluding to that
collect uh this public performance makes
them sound like secret cabal society
they um they're called Pros performance
royalty organizations
um and each country has one that's like
has essentially they operate that
territory so
um I'm suddenly blanking on the name of
the one that is the Australian one
um uh
but that's the UK one
um yeah no I I talked to them regularly
they're so lovely um no
Austin's gonna start again you'd be our
Oracle
come on you can do this I know
it's it's something it's uh it is a you
always say is it magma uh no no no no
Twice Australian games
audio ago well it's not a games thing
there um oh it's like because it doesn't
audience yeah
um so yeah the uh
um their whole thing is they pay
royalties on public exhibition of music
so like it all started as it started
with tin pen alley composers in the US
they created ASCAP and BMI as the two
rival ones that paid on live theater
performances of Music where the
performer was not the composer so they
were like we need to find a way to
create an Avenue for a composer to make
money when their music is being sung
like in a theater and then that became
like the big money maker then was like
the
television and radio weren't really you
know mainstream the television didn't
even exist and radio was not what it you
know was to become because this was all
you know over 100 years ago now or
approximately 100 years ago
um and then they were like that's very
much public exhibition
um and so composers
um and weirdly movie theaters in the U.S
do not count as public exhibition but
everywhere else in the world they do so
if you score a Marvel movie for example
that crushes it in Theatrical box office
around the world you can make literally
millions of dollars just as the composer
uh but you'll get zero from the US and
then airs on television if it shows up
on TV and obviously streaming is like
one of the big Battlegrounds now because
streaming makes a fraction of what
television does in terms of those
relatives but interestingly PRS which is
the UK one uh the that probably stands
for performance royalty Society or
whatever but it's the UK one of these
they made a deal specifically with Sony
so that sales of games on the
PlayStation Store in the UK count so I
actually get royalties on every game
I've ever scored
when it's sold in the UK no way on
PlayStations that's awesome so it's like
a subset of a subset of a subset but but
that was like the idea and the hope is
that that represents uh a Tipping Point
and they're able to broker more because
the big one they're hoping they can
figure out is Twitch
um because that is that is basically
television but the main thing everyone's
worried about is all the automated
content ID [__]
um trips up where like right now the
Publishers the Publishers have defaulted
to to basically trying to not involve
the royalty organizations because
people's streams get interrupted or
demonetized right because of uh I had a
sponsored stream get pulled because
there was a licensed song in it that I
was unable to turn off so even though
the sponsor was paying me to stream it
it got Auto flagged because of a song in
the game and I feel like from my
perspective as someone who does not
produce music is that YouTube does quite
a good job they no okay I'm willing to
accept that so so the YouTube system
also doesn't work on on your site either
the problem is they're automating
something that's super complicated and
there's no like person you can call so
like so like okay case in point when
aliens fire team came out we had many
months of the game being out where there
was no soundtrack album and the album
like data is what ultimately is getting
fed because they're not like they're not
taking the music from the game files or
whatever
commercial it's the commercialization
they would have had nothing to flag not
that that you saw the first slack video
games I've never seen anybody do that
other than Nintendo but
well they don't do it on purpose but it
happens automatically by mistake all the
time because what happens is we we
didn't have an album out so there are
streamers and YouTubers and everybody
you know who's playing fire team has no
issues then uh Hollywood Records which
is owned by Disney because Fox is owned
by Disney and fox is the IP holder for
uh the aliens franchise they put out the
soundtrack album and suddenly it was
like all these all these vods and
streams are just all overnight including
I had uploaded like I do nerdy behind
the scenes videos and stuff on my own
YouTube channel and I had a bunch of all
my videos got taken down overnight as
well and so I called the developer and I
called the Disney folks and I was like
you're screwing yourself because I said
never mind that it's an inconvenience
for me but all these streamers and stuff
like this is a game that that's fun it's
a co-op
that's a big part of the audience you're
screwing yourself if those streams are
getting shut down and the best they
could do in the short term was just
whitelist my channel yes um and I was
like that's lame though that's that's
that's a damn that's that's poking a
hole in like all these leaking spots in
the dam I said that's that's not solving
the bigger problem but the thing was no
one did this on purpose because now
there is a series of options when you
upload it right where you can specify
the level of uh aggression that you want
the algorithm to take as I recall kinda
it's it's a little bit I wish that I
wish they
or specific like we had this recently I
don't know are you worried about that
with straight Gods when you've made the
four albums or because you're not
through a publisher with that is that
not going to be an issue well so I was
just about to say we just had this drama
just recently and I'm I'm hoping it's
solved but because I am administering
it was weird though where where like I
always put things up where I'm like I
don't want there to be any restrictions
um like there should be no it's okay
with me sometimes the system will
acknowledge it will recognize what it is
but then just say you're good like it
will it will say we see that this piece
is that but there's no there's no issues
obviously the you know in a sense the
ideal word is world is sort of like how
it was on the beginning days of fire
team where it didn't even know that
there was music there it just sees it as
audio and it can't differentiate it from
people talking or something yeah but
once the music is now out like on
Spotify and stuff that there's an
imprint of that file that it can
recognize even underneath other stuff
it's actually pretty amazing when you
think about it super technology they
also have an editing software where I've
never actually tried it but you can just
mute music so I guess the AI knows to
just mute the music track and leave
everything else which is crazy the same
it's the same way that you get those
those videos of people being like here's
the isolated vocal of Freddie Mercury or
whatever true where there you can you
can go and sculpt out everything that's
not the voice we can do the flip we can
we can you know mute the music yeah yeah
I think I think a lot of karaoke stuff
like that all the time yeah exactly like
that it's pretty impressive and so
anyway yeah so we had an issue just the
other day where I literally Katie from
from summer fall uh messages me and was
like our Tick Tock just got flagged for
our our trailer including the music from
our own trailer and I was like I was
like I don't get it I I completely and
what we discovered is that Tick Tock is
just a wild west of insanity and they
just make and change their own rules
randomly and like because it wasn't a
YouTube problem and it wasn't I was as
far as I could tell it what did you get
flagged by
it thought that the music was not
permitted to be included basically based
on nothing
yes wow because because it knows the MU
here was my hypothesis
you can you can just like make an audio
file like a trailer like it's it is a
bespoke piece of audio that has been
mixed and has voice over and like sound
effects of text coming on screen and all
that and you can upload that as a
component part of a video and so like
you know how it'll say original sound or
whatever in the audio description
it it sees there it sees basically
copyrighted material as a component part
of that original sound
and it it does not work it does not
allow that but if you upload a thing
without music and then use their
internal database to find it and add it
as like part of The Tick Tock app then
it knows it's fine and it lets you do
that so my hypothesis was it was because
they basically didn't like that we
didn't search for it within Tick Tock uh
because you know people will just like
record themselves and then they'll
search for a song they like within Tick
Tock because you didn't do it the right
way they just assumed that it was
copyrighted content based on nothing and
there yeah and there are like also
different kinds of accounts on Tick Tock
so like a business account can't use any
copyrighted music whereas a just a
regular person's account can use any
music even if it is curated sorry like
our theory was that maybe our account
because it is above a set and follow the
threshold is in like a third category
where it's like not quite one or the
other
um it'll seems we seem to have resolved
it
um but or it has resulted on itself but
yeah like it is it is a it's always a
worry whenever you release anything like
this like it's also when music is the
game in this case
that's why we were really glad that it
didn't break anything else because like
we would have known very quickly yeah
yeah I I um I I had my I have like a
ghost YouTube channel where I upload
things to see if they're gonna get um
struck before like like my private
well I I like to because I don't know if
my account has any sort of flags or like
whitelisting or something so we we
um we uh because the you know I just
they they're so they're so shady on the
algorithms like for example I don't
monetize my channel ever and so certain
permissions I think change once you do
and so I'm like so we just my assistant
I created a a dummy Channel and I'll
just like I took we have these four
albums coming out for stray gods and I
uploaded all four in their entirety onto
the ghost Channel just to make sure that
it all hell didn't break and all four
were completely left alone so it was
like okay well that's a very good sign
that we're not gonna get [__] yes
would you have any issue with somebody
doing that it was just like uploading
people
yeah well because we have we've had two
demos so there are like lots of people
who have been like oh here is like every
path through next song
um except that as it I'm almost certain
that they actually didn't nobody yet has
captured every part through either plan
or Apollo and put it on YouTube every
every single one I've seen I'm like
that's not comprehensive I think my
favorite was on the very first day of
our first the Ludo nericon demo when
like an hour in somebody uploaded like a
20 minute video that said pan every path
and it was three yeah it was three runs
through it and I was like oh bless your
heart not even close yeah they just did
like the good the bad the middle like
they didn't yeah well I think that they
did one on that I think they've said
like uh like yeah yeah the three
different traits yeah and then left it
at that it doesn't occur to them that
behind every there's three doors and
behind each of those four doors and so
like it you know it there are some
places where it will it creates a false
illusion of maybe there being only three
because in the case of the Pan song
There it it the paths Converge on three
one of three possibilities before
branching back out again so like if you
play it three ways and you choose each
one of those three it might create the
impression oh I see there's basically
three variations of this song but it's
like
um
there's actually way more than that
um I actually just had it's gonna be fun
for you guys to watch like it's again
like so branching in this case every
time different playthroughs
I still see new stuff like I've worked
this game for five years and every now
and then I will come across like I know
or like a part of a song that I
literally never heard before that's so
cool and it's wild
yeah it was it was fun to I I have a
version of that there's definitely some
that I hear much less frequently
um and
um that's why I'll send even as recently
as like a few weeks ago I'll send Liam a
message I'm like can you open the editor
and just remind me how we even get to
this this one because I'm looking at my
documents and they're kind of
contradicting each other and so then
Liam opens it and we're like screen
sharing going okay so you have to do
this and then this and then this so if
you also do this then that's how you'll
reveal that bit because I worked on the
game for as long as you have and you
both have that is amazing
it's David is the only one who truly has
it all in his head and crazy
even even then like with the songs he's
often like
so big
that that just also just like swinging
it back to Baldur's Gate knowing how
what we did
and then like you play a game that or
like divinity original sin two where you
just go
their their version of that is scary
um just the sheer amount of
contingencies and and the fact that like
yeah
there's no real like I remember when I
first started playing Divinity I [__]
love that game me too and and I was like
I just realized I like you spent all
this time crafting your main character
in the opening of the game and then you
can just kind of like abandon them well
sometimes you have to because you I
didn't realize that a fire and a water
spell would cancel each other out the
Character Creator did I
and like after like 40 hours you have to
respect like it's yeah and you realize
you realize like this thing is
is is so variable I just kept thinking
yeah and the fact that there's character
replies to virtually every NPC like one
of your members of your party will chime
in in a way that's sort of reasonably
specific to them and I just thought the
spreadsheets
uh yeah they're wild like I when we were
working on
creative Dragon Spiel and bullet Boulder
skate to enhanced Edition which is weird
it's like I've worked on Baldur's Gate
before which is very strange uh David
Dave and I both have like really
complicated feelings around Baldur's
Gate 3 I think
um we're very excited for it but it's
also like we worked on the series uh for
such a long time that we had a very
specific idea of like what a Baldur's
Gate 3 would look like
um so I'm really excited to see what
bears is but like interjections like
from party NPCs in other dialogues were
always one of my favorite Parts yeah
because they make the world come alive
but they're also so complicated to do
well I asked I haven't heard back from
PRN I don't want to put them on the spot
right now or anything
um but I would really love to have some
writers for that game on my writing
podcast because I just can't even fathom
how they did it it's RPG dialogue is is
wild yeah I've had to write something
before and it was even that for me to
make sure that every line fed into
whatever the next line was going to be
without the performance being strange I
just had to act it out myself every time
so I've written you know like branching
dialogue for three pages and then I have
to go through and pick every choice and
speak it out loud which I do not
normally do just to make sure these made
senses sentences which is like so much
extra work even as it is its own skill
it's it's wild to me because that's
actually how I started writing
um and so like it comes to me very
naturally now but uh
it's the most [__] up way to write
yeah let's be clear as well people are
talking about Santa Monica Studio just
so nobody makes that a inaccurate Reddit
headline like the time that I said
Atlanta has done a ton of stuff gang I
said saved on this podcast once and they
thought I said same
um and it got to Reddit which is really
stupid so to be clear I'm not talking
about San Juan
and to to your point Liam David's
ability to somehow retain all those
independent branches and clear in his
head is so bizarre where we'd be working
on a song and I go wouldn't it be cool
if you know if like Grace says this and
he'd go well seven scenes earlier
there's this one possible line that if
you do X and Y she'll say this with
Freddy and then that would potentially
contradict this or not so we might need
to have two versions in the song
depending on what the player chose in
those early and you're like
like I'm like start over what's the and
I'm like trying to look up in the
documentation where's the thing and he's
just split patiently like
catch up with me here and it's just yeah
I was blown away his ability to retain
uh it's very funny because it finally
it's only true while he's working on it
and then as soon as he's like
it'll just so like you ask him about
it yeah like it it's it's wild but then
he'll remember we also about Dragon Age
my favorite thing about working with
David sometimes you can ask like some
obscure Dragon Age question and he won't
actually remember the correct law he'll
remember the law from a version three
versions before they shipped
um and it's my favorite thing in the
world to to be like wait was that the
shipped version or was that a version
launch at SMS it's being like wait is
this the Canon or is that a thing I
spoke about in a meeting three years ago
it's very confusing the names are the
worst
like the the we renamed all of the songs
for like in stray God's pretty recently
I would say right Austin like oh yeah
a lot of the songs I have to check again
to remember what we settled on as the
final because it's still very I mean I
still think I began this thing called
Idols so yeah I'm slow to change I don't
even think of the game as being called
chorus
so yeah I don't say it I don't see
anyone listening that was like our
original code name for the game uh like
before that it was Project Bacchus
because we needed something
um and uh yeah but it's wild that like I
I've been with these names for months
and months and months and I still have
to do like uh tan song I mean I can
teach you yeah this is how it was like
introduced to your dream ingrained on
how we wrote it like yeah
so when is the review involvement
review embargo is tomorrow how are you
feeling about that
curious I don't know how I'm gonna react
like other games that have worked I'm
like I mean I work on Siege of
dragonspear which was you know not well
rated at launch
um and uh I've worked on games that you
know had were very well rated at launch
everyone is different like your
reactions like every single game like I
don't know what your experience has been
but like mine has always it's been
wildly variable I think this one I'm
tired like I'm very very tired and so I
think that that will filter through and
probably give me some distance
um I think I'll probably Focus Less on
specifics and more on like the general
picture which is also an experience
thing too
um but uh they're in invariably like
there'll be some review where they'll
say something and I'll be like that's
just so wrong and I'll fixate on that
and I'll be like oh my God like if you
haven't
told you yeah yeah how about yours and
how are you feeling about it
yeah
um
I I feel cautiously optimistic I feel
like
um
I feel like it's enough of because
there's so little to measure it against
um I think that people will actually
kind of look at it on its own terms in a
lot of games which is right yeah well in
most games
kind of understandably are not given
that like I went and saw Indiana Jones
with Troy and the first thing out of his
mouth when we got out of the theater
afterward was if there weren't other
Indiana Jones movies this would be a
really great movie oh you know like like
it like if if we weren't measuring it
against some of the most beloved films
we would have a different measuring
stick you know fundamentally and we
can't even imagine that aspect Andromeda
yeah I've seen I've seen the argument
that that game was given almost an un
like setting aside the bugs and stuff
they had at launched and the fact that
they had to they were kind of forced to
launch you know pretty uh schedule yeah
um setting all that aside just on its
own I agree like it had a lot to it it
just was coming on the back of like the
most cherished and beloved yeah Trilogy
ever and so yeah I was so I feel like we
have the advantage of not that baggage
which I think I think if you look at it
objectively and and you see that it's
not trying to be like I thought it one
of the best ideas that you all had
Liam of like this subtitle of a
role-playing musical
um
as a way to say we are not an RPG and I
love I love David put that Twitter
thread out a few weeks ago or whatever
saying let's set some expectations of
RPG evokes a certain type of game
and we're not even trying to be that
we're that we don't have any semblance
of that and so we want to distance
ourselves and I I the analogy I keep
drawing as I said
we're so we're so committed to the the
pure sense of what role-playing is that
I said it's almost like improv theater
where other than the fact that as a
piece of software with pre-recorded
lines we was only so far you can't
actually improvise to the fullest
extents of what a real improv group can
be but we're trying to evoke what that
feels like where it's like well what do
I what is my reaction in this moment I
want to think on my feet and kind of yes
and my way through this situation that's
way closer to what we're trying to do
than when you think of like okay I gotta
build my party and I want to think in
terms of like what sort of specs my
character has and all the [__] that we
love RPGs for we're not even trying to
do that and so I feel like reviewers
broadly speaking
I I just I don't know if I'm being
idealistic or I feel like they will get
that and then whether they like it or
not on its own terms will be whatever it
shakes out to be but we're not going to
be sitting there reading these reviews
like what the [__] are you comparing us
to Baldur's Gate for or whatever when
yeah like we're just not even trying to
be that you know you may as well compare
us to GTA or or Call of Duty or
something at that point like we're just
not doing that and and proudly not like
we're we found our own thing that we
were excited about and I I feel like I
feel like they'll they'll get that
whether they end up liking it or not is
a separate thing but I would be so
frustrated if the reviews felt like they
just fundamentally missed even the
aspiration
so we'll hopefully hopefully I'm not
wrong even on that front I certainly
feel that way viewers will be picked
based in accordance with people who
understand and are excited about the
genre I would yeah like the kind of the
kind of people who want to review it are
probably people who are likely to
understand it I think the other thing as
a game developer
is that you will judge your own game
hasha than any reviewer could it's like
I know like I absolutely know every
floor that stray God's had and every
single one I am way harsher on them than
anyone else like Austin and I have gone
back and forth like the like when we
were fixing bugs for example like I know
there are bugs in there that haven't
been fixed that I'm like oh my God like
I God I wish Austin there was there's
one bug where it's time is is
desynced by two seconds because or it
was it's I think it's fixing seconds but
two seconds because there was a piece of
score that somehow like either had
shifted or like the the end piece of
score for the previous section had moved
somehow and I I don't know how it
happened but like nobody could fire off
until
Liam deserves so much credit for for the
different
Liam spent so much time in engine doing
audio specific work like what person
who's in a studio leadership role is
also the one going now should this
transition happen at nine milliseconds
or ten milliseconds like we got into the
[__] like really really deep in it
wasn't high level it was the lowest
level that audio gets
yeah I'm I think we were
at our smallest we're probably like five
at our biggest I think we were with 25.
damn
um
so like for what we made it's like
I don't know how he did it the fact that
we have as many actors as developers
yeah that's nuts
um yeah it's it's uh yeah but the audio
department is essentially Steve Green
myself and sort of Liam online uh and uh
and um we had additional sound design as
well
um but um but yeah it was it was anyway
Liam gets a lot of credit for that and I
definitely there was I found a mistake
in in I can't remember if we talked
about it or not but one of the songs I
won't say which one because I don't want
to encourage people to find it but I did
find a I did find a pathway mistake
um in one of the songs where I was like
it's possible for the character to
reference something that they might not
have heard
um and it's really subtle but it's like
we we worked so hard to make it feel
like these callbacks are all contextual
to your choices the way like a musical
theater is all about callbacks and I
realized I found I found one it's pretty
obscure but I was like [__] and I'm like
it's I have to always be put in my place
where I my I I put every bug as this is
game breaking we can't ship
[Laughter]
I have a bit of a hard time like
hierarchically categorizing bugs of like
okay this one this one can go it tends
to be either Red Alert or like not quite
as red alert for me uh I fully
acknowledge it's a flaw this is why I am
not in charge
um but um yeah
[Laughter]
um well we want to keep you fight
anymore longer uh Liam thank you so much
for staying up late for us I appreciate
it I'm going super late over there
um where can people I'm excited to know
if they would like to know more about
you you can find me uh at Liam ASLA
l-i-a-m-e-s-l-e-r on pretty much any
social media platform in fact pretty
much all of them
um and I might even post sometimes and
where can people get stray Gods what
what it's out now on
oh God things straight guards the role
playing musical out now on
uh PC on which you can access it via
steam epic game store or good old games
uh you can get it on
PS5 PS4 Xbox One Xbox series s and x and
Nintendo switch
I wanna I never wanna release another
game on so many platforms all at once so
much it was the heinous yeah um shout
out to plastic Fern who helped us a lot
with that but yes go go buy straight
gods and play it and then uh tell us
what you think yeah I'm very very
excited to hear everybody check it out
I'm sure we'll continue to talk about it
uh after another play it this week as
well very excited uh yeah thanks for
joining us Liam thanks for being here
Austin appreciate it my pleasure thank
you see you all in a couple of weeks
probably who knows bye-bye
thank you
[Music]